foreign
[Music]
my name is Tom Mock I'm the workbench
product manager here at Plaza I've kind
of Built My Career thinking about the
developer experience so worked in the
Cordo team as a product manager thinking
about how we integrate R and python
together for notebooks and extending
them and now I'm focusing almost all of
my time on the developer experience for
workbench and integrating R and python
there for data scientists and their
daily work
[Music]
posit team is kind of our Crown Jewel or
bundle of all of our professional
products so you have three kind of parts
to this that all are complementary but
also isolated products so maybe you only
need one or maybe you need all of them
but you all get to make that choice in
terms of flexibility
so posit workbench is your workbench
where your data scientists your data
analysts the people who write our python
SQL they get their work done we provide
an authenticated workspace with you know
Best in Class Enterprise single sign-on
and saml and the things you would expect
but we also provide multiple
environments for those data scientists
to get their work done so of course you
have our studio for people who are maybe
doing a mix of R and python you can
execute code there we've also got more
traditional and kind of expected pure
python environments so we have access to
Jupiter lab as well as classic Jupiter
notebooks and then vs code which is this
very open-ended and flexible integrated
development environment is also
available on workbench posit workbench
provides an IDE vs code Jupiter Jupiter
lab or Studio some place to do that work
eventually though you want to get it off
of that environment where you both track
how it's performing there but also how
it affect part of your business or
integrate with other parts of your
company
so as soon as you're ready to get it off
of your local environment you can deploy
it to connect you can have a command
line where you kind of write it up the
application and then you deploy it with
authentication into connect but you can
also integrate it into Version Control
or kind of continuous integration and
continuous deployment where it goes into
something like GitHub or git lab and
then gets pulled automatically into
connect
the last part of it would be positive
package manager again with open source
you have all this flexibility but with
flexibility can sometimes come
complexity positive package manager is
really this backbone behind all of our
other tooling ultimately to do open
source data science you need open source
data science libraries and packages so
positive package manager allows you to
host both your own python packages so
you can create your own wheels upload
them to positive package manager and
have them stored there as well as grab
subsets or all of Pi Pi and kind of the
other open source packages that the
whole Community is working on so that
really takes away a lot of the headache
of having to manage more complex
structures like you don't have to use
Docker you don't have to use tools like
Honda you don't have to manage all these
system dependencies you're really
focused on Purely writing python code
and indicating what are the libraries or
packages that provide the functionality
I want so python at its most simple is
part of what posit team provides for you
[Music]
positive historically has been known for
the r Studio IDE that's kind of our
Crown Jewel of developer experience for
our users we've done a lot of
Investments for pipeline users as well
however and so we have Cordo we have
vetiver we have all these open source
tools that really try to make data
science seamless for python users so
part of our investment in open source is
that we are both doing it ourselves and
integrating with others so if you think
about posit the company about half of
our company is engineering about half of
our Engineers are working purely on open
source so we're making huge investments
in terms of people hours in improving
and maintaining professionally supported
open source data science packages over
time you might have shifts in how you're
developing your your tooling or writing
your models and we want to kind of
future proof the platform so that as new
framers come out we're adding those in
and making sure that they're supported
and we're testing against them as well
as allowing them to be deployed into
things on production
[Music]